[Music]  a new clip has been released from peter  jackson's the hobbit which is going to  open this friday and uh i was checking  out the clip and you know it's been a  couple of years since the lord of the  rings and i was watching the clip i  found gollum much scarier than i  remembered him yeah take a look  my name  is bilbo baggins  [Applause]  do you understand  [Applause]  [Music]  the only thing that confuses me about  that clip is in in what context was  honey boo boo going  that's the part that freaks me out  clearly we took it from the show but at  one one of the shows you go  somebody tried to take the precious  does she do that i don't know